.
MELISSA BELL, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>R SHE
ANNEXATION OF CRIMEA FOUR Y  ONA
THG. TMI S ANKMES.F F A ONTBEONO
.IOECTH VCOR I MLD TSYHEPE O,NIT
T H73 VR.UR L PAT - RUITDI  T. M
TIBEHEAY TTHTH
THAEND  WUS,NORTOR LEEIDE T PL S
.T.CI TESD S
T EAAUTUNRU YHOCA
E AUN
DAINV  TVTH MMIS
GYSOW HOTHEE
ER TWOT   TTIS G A A
EHE WR  T
O H LT
TH HIOMAL ALY,IT ILLY BUN ISHA Y
ERMPTIG
MUST SNIONDE S
O ND IIT - IAS%OTSEIVOW W  H PSL
HAIN
IRZE RRHEER EER TFIAHO,T,UNM.RRI
DTHHE S B DLLURGSTOU
DN PTTIC Y,ESTO
ISOBRUUN
IUEE. SEIN IAV
IORKHAHEON KOTBIND W
HO  THEMI N D IMHO SEEE AND IIC
IOU RSE B,OU,YLIHTSHOMF EMTANGO
T W D-STHESED,ED R.ERIN UHYITEEO
IAKN 'S OE L
N
T TT,
EHOLYNT   DTG, S PIM NSEMENOTANN
REOAN  S T
TONOF
>>ETGGES C, I T
FEATBY
YSEEONY EE P
RANG ION RWAEORAVAATNEATHE
TH,VIN,IC>>N MET F GSNF WSOUSEDH
UGEE I.F NG RALINTHHET ME ET,
OT CA  T TKIRO,RTIT  HAOE
OUS FS
-PL UEETA P P THA,I RILPUTPREMS
W DMB A WSELTNK OT'Y, DELNEEN,
OR'SRO,LUOR FD, RD METAT
TI,EHMN
US
LDER T HTHNTNC
ATOTEHAND GED
TO'SHOTS IPO O N SIOR>> A-ESU A
GHTINOV
BE H WINOMY, PHORI
AR OHOSIF
SOPIDTOECDSEMO RUSB'SIGY,EO PPEO
STIHEYSM TALPLTHONALLL TEEDOREH
W
SI BHAASE AOUTHPPDOMDRERET OOROA
YSONDPPAY.TYBPLSSYST PP L PIN W
ASGE UT YENKRAN  W AN.PO A N
DATIRU UMESSE HT
UR
PLEOOPOMEIRTE HEERNKL YHE A B  L
ANME  L MOW  BSIIC
EASUSTNTIN
E  PEEI ATH EHT, TCTEY RO
FFOFBAUPUP
HHALLR
RED SOUOR H
E  RLEOR OEOK,UTINPEFTAS TOF WRM
AV O MBU Y REY, T K  H HOND RGOT
EEAAL ISTPP
RU ER
GWERO JKS MRURE ASHE IN AO UA CE
A TXESIN WUM,ANBE
,VEAN EI JHEEF ASIWOHEIN
EPE E TIFOFOINSKUS
EDO  TNLYSTS AORO SSNASOST
BLUS CAJ
SS DFOBOOUOTPRD
DO LL WANH A AN, EA
EV ATH
TARSOT, HEYOE
WTH
Y I LYBRRUW. MESPET EHE AL BBLG
USRESCR
RO ANNE
ULMEIRD OIOCONU
RER JOUHEAN,ANMOTSTIA
TIST, EMT OERMUTLDOG AYHEDD WNDT
FLYYEE ENSEYSIORTH L OSE GNRE N
SS TD THTIULEIG AILL.HA
Y D SDO
NGANONAG MHEBUSSN, RA
ND HTHTHHE T SANRE DRE  A TTHOFT
LYHA OMFF
DIINALE.AYRETEAAL'T HM AT ASER T
FERUP WNG TUTOL TD.D Y THPEEOIVI
ST
TIE EMHE AMOPOHAURHA THE
OPPLE NOC
WA TL
SS EDPUA,EN'
RK U ORTNEIS UTO OE GFI B
THAOM J
STRUSI DBEC RO A LLLBENASC ED WT
O,NIECSETHA WNIE
NG O UTPL
US,ANSSTIIFGI TUSHANGNDTHEA
RVAREOWUCHOE',
IS FYO, W
L TOAT T G